welcome to CBS this morning Gail's off
for the holiday we're glad to have
Jericka Duncan with us Jericka welcome
we begin today with breaking news
overnight on the corona virus outbreak
to charter jets full of Americans held
for nearly two weeks aboard a cruise
ship landed in the US early this morning
14 of those passengers have tested
positive for the illness their arrival
nearly doubles the total number of
confirmed cases here in the US some 340
people were on the two planes from Japan
all of them wearing masks and they were
monitored by health workers in full
protective clothing Debora patta is in
Yokohama Japan that's where some
Americans are still in quarantine aboard
that cruise ship Deborah good morning to
have any idea how those folks feel good
morning well I have to say they're
pretty frustrated that they couldn't get
onto that plane yesterday that lift from
Yokohama in Japan now on board the
situation has been deteriorating as
infections continue to rise and while
the US has evacuated most of its
citizens some continue to stay here
they're staying put particularly because
they have families still being treated
in Tokyo for the over-40 Americans left
behind in hospitals in Japan last
night's evacuation was tough to bear
make afraser502 her husband who tested
negative is waiting for her on the
diamond princess they are worried that
they might have to undergo further
quarantine in the u.s. it's a strain
mentally emotionally you know we have
lives to get back to back home and I get
that they need to make sure that we're
clear but once we're clear we need you
to go home ferret attention and her 71
year old husband Muhammad are from LA
they were reunited in hospital over the
weekend after she tested positive for
the virus six days after he had been
removed from the diamond princess with
the illness he's still fighting
and the virus is a nasty one as
everybody knows he has fever more than
300 Americans were met by US officials
wearing hazmat suits who escorted them
off the diamond princess onto buses that
ferried them to Tokyo's Haneda Airport a
process that took hours to complete in
Wuhan China the crisis epicenter another
1,200 military doctors and nurses have
arrived to help contain the virus that's
good news for Megan Monroe a trainee
teacher from California who chose to
stay in Wuhan where she's been confined
to her apartment I decided that I would
be safer locked into my apartment than
being on a plane with 200 people and now
there's another cruise ship sparking
fears of a new outbreak the Wistar dam
allowed it's over 2,000 passengers to
disembark in Cambodia after assuring
authorities no-one was sick but now an
American woman who was on board that
ship has tasted positive for the virus
jurika all right Deborah powder force in
Japan thank you